so first I'd like to thank the
organizers for the invitation to to come
to the program and to speak here I'm
looking forward to the other docs and
then to interact with some of you doing
in the time I'm here I want to talk
about joint work with Aaron herro and
it's based on this paper which is on the
archive and will be about you know
quantum probability careful proofs and I
will explain what what they are and and
about putting limitations on on what or
what we feed it's possible to do and so
please stop me at any point if you have
any question i am going to face blow me
down and if i'm to slope just tell me
and variable so i just want to start
very slowly just remind you what
constraint satisfaction problems are and
how we can define a quadrant
generalization of them so they are very
simple so i will put some parameters
here so a constraint satisfaction
problem depends on on four parameters
one is the energy so it is basically a
constraint satisfaction problem is just
a number of variables like the exes here
and some constraints on these variables
and this constraint should only act on a
few of the variables each one of them so
k is the number of variables that each
constraint excellent for example here
free in the picture yet another parent
is the alphabet is how many is is is the
space over which the variables can vary
so for example eric alphabet means that
X can be either 0 1 and so on don't have
the number of variables and it's just
the number of axis here and we have the
number of constraints just a number of
seeds so the constraint is just in the
simplest case that we also consider here
is just a function from from the space
of full decade fold space of the
alphabet 201 so you can feel the
constraint size fight if it's zero is
violated if it's one and now we like to
put some assignment on these variables
assign values to these variables such
that we satisfy the maximum number of
constraints possible so the assignment
is just some function from from the set
of variables here right so we have n
variables and to each very
we put one of the wells in the alphabet
and I was interesting seeing here is how
many of these constraints can satisfy
right so maybe we can satisfy all of
them great but maybe we can only satisfy
a certain number of them we want to find
the assignment which satisfy the maximum
number of constraints right so this is
the former so we can define what we call
on sats value of the constant
satisfaction problem see and then we
just minimize over all possible
assignments and this is the average
number of constraints being violated
right so this is between zero and one if
it's zero all the constraints are
satisfied if it's one all of them are
violated and we want we might want to
compute this all right so called cost
race I section partners we just do
almost the same thing but we generalize
a little bit in our definition of this
local constraints so so now we ok let's
call it h because we connect some
Hamiltonian later as we saw in Daniel
stock here we have the eris again with
all these localities as well is how many
how many of the variables each
constraint depends on now instead of
alphabet we have some local dimension
that again now number of variables is
just their cubits or units right it is
bigger than two and we have the number
of constraints as well now the only
difference is that the constraints now
instead of being these functions they
are in the most simplest case
projections okay and and K local
projections so they are projection
projector projector matrix which only
acts not revealing in at most K of the
of the qubits ok I'll give you example
next slide if it's not here now because
we are in this no commuting problem
right to have this project instead of
this function the assignor is not just
some some big screen for the variables
when all is a quantum state side and we
and their SATs now is really the quantum
states which violates the most number of
constraints and hear how we define when
we want to minimize overall quantum
states this average violation so we have
M constraints we divide by the number of
constraints and we see this expectation
value there's some of each one of this
load constraints pigeon right so it's
like the probability of measuring
like 0 namely pj when we are in the
quantum step side right and there is a
better way of writing this like this is
just we minimize over States is just a
minimum i can value these hermitian
matrix so it we can also write these in
terms of 1 over m times the minimum
eigen value of the hamiltonian so two
examples just if you never saw this to
make it here suppose you have a
constraint satisfaction problem a
quantum one on the localities to so each
each of these constraints only depends
on two of the qubits then the alphabet
is true so it's like cubes right so two
dimensional quantum systems or name
particles and we have n minus 1
constraints so we are on the line for
example here then we just have some
constraint satisfaction problem it's
just we call upon to hang with tony is
the sum of these local terms and why I
mean by local terms is the terms have
this form so for example the term J and
J plus 1 it's trivial everywhere its
identity everywhere except on qubits JM
j plus 1 and there is just any
projection you wanna put I'm focus on
projects for simplicity could consider
any revision matrix if you want but
let's let's focus on projects on this
talk so this is one example right
another example that shows that this
quantum constraint satisfaction problems
are generalization of the classic one is
just to see what happens if again we
have locality to write on cubits and NM
and variables M constraints but now we
have diagonal projectors and let let's
put the projects of this form right so
they are just this classical constraints
from before and now some basis new
computational bits oh right and now if
you can compute this on sat why is this
minimum I gonville then because this
this is diagonal in the computational
basis the optimal states will be
diagonally computational basis and you
can do a calculation see this is equal
to minimum over all assignments to this
quantity and if you just put the
diffusion of bj you see that this is
exactly the start of the classical
problem okay so so if you want to just
forget about quantum mechanics and
everything you can just think of this as
some net
zation of constraint satisfaction
problems right all right so so the main
result about transvestite sexual
problems that i won't consider in this
talk is the pcp furor i'm sure many of
you have heard of it before so it's
result by many people include a chair so
first proven in 98 and and they stadium
is the following they showed that there
is some universal constant epsilon such
that it's empty hard to determine
whether for a given constraint
satisfaction problem the lsat this gyro
so you have a satisfied by assignment or
the lsat is bigger than epson okay so so
why this is very interesting and very
strong results because if you just look
at google atmosphere right that to see
whether a constraints I session problem
is size 5 or not one way to to formulate
as a receiver problem is to tell whether
the uncertain 0 or them sat is bigger
than 1 over m the number of constraints
here the SAT is a constant right so
either they are all the constraints a
size file or a constant fraction of them
is not satisfied all right in even this
very a first side very easy problem it's
you buy that right it's NP hard okay so
the name comes from from the fact that
no using these results you can find a
new way of writing proofs for four NP
problems as in terms of probabilistic
checkbook groups I won't get into that
they are Daniel radiation in the block
so later like nine years layers dunno
came up with a more coconut oil proof of
the same results and we will touch on
this proof a little bit later I and its
first a very beautiful result but it's
also very useful right so it's really
the central to when you want to do
hardness of approximation right so when
you want to find the limits of how well
you can approximate like many common
Atari optimization problems the PCP is
is really this awesome point right so so
given this and given that we have this
quantum version of constraint
satisfaction problems it's it's natural
to ask whether there is a version of
this results right
but alas this first we have to see if
there is a notion of of NP hardness in
the quantum case and there is one right
then and then I already explained so
this is like the quantum cook Levin
theorem and one formulation of it do
took a dive is using this local
Hamiltonian problem so here we have
again a quantum constraint satisfaction
problem locality k local dimension G and
then we have low calcium and local
dementia constant the number of
constraints in is polynomially the
number of qubits and the ball of the
problem is who decides if they are subs
is 0 or if it's bigger than they'll pay
for some some things built so a few ties
proved is that this problem is complete
for a class when our quantum class
called qma when this delta is
sufficiently small like 1 over
polynomial in n so this qm is just we
saw before it's just the quad monologue
of NP right is exactly like NP but they
put is a quantum is so the proof is the
quantum states and the verification
procedure is a quantum computation it's
polynomial quantum computation alright
so so this is an interesting result
first because it's a very natural
problem right Hamiltonians they're
important in physics as well and and
actually it shows that this problem this
quantum turn problem it's actually
harder than the classical one right so
if we believe that qma is not equal to
NP that we cannot prove it but we
believe it's the case then actually to
solve this problem the quantum case
requires is much higher than solving for
classical for classical Hamiltonian all
right so so what what's the quantum PCP
conjecture so what what we want to do is
to state something which is similar to
to the classical PCP by now for cure me
okay and we cannot prove if it's true or
not it's the open question by Elise we
can state up possible connection right
so so one way to state this project
should be to say that again there is
some universal constants
so that the following problem is qma
completes so given a constraint
satisfaction problem quantum locality to
and local dimension to for example we
want let their mind whether it's
satisfiable so they on sat easy row or
whether they're on sat valleys bigger
than epsilon ok so the same thing is as
for the class squad so of course we can
change the lock is in the local
dimension right so like any any concept
you want this doesn't change the
conjecture so it was proven that the
conjecture is equivalent to this much in
our case we know this is np-hard this
problem right by the classical PCP
theorem we also know this is inside qma
because even when their status is like 1
over 1 or apollyon follow me men it's
inside Q&A so the question is where it
sits in between right it is equal to
actually this is inside MP or executive
a hat the conjecture Said's qma heart so
what oblations when they are constant
but will be very interesting if you can
prove versions even when whole dick us
then so it's I I don't remember but I
think blog wouldn't be enough but log
log my deed or del all right works I
think was worse than exponential how the
price you pay from home Watson but I
don't remember exactly when and to show
all my treat burleson this problem even
for commuting quadruple straight side
section problems we put all these
constraints to commute right there's a
minute a diagonal enough in the
computational Bass they only commute it
could be that you know be doable if it's
short accommodates qma hugs it could be
the excellently all right so so while we
interesting in this problem I won't say
much but I just want to say a few things
first I feel be nice to have not some
hardness of approximation result for Q&A
this 20 this would give that in terms of
all physics ready it will give a show
quantum hardness of computing mean
ground energy mean I mean like the
energy per interaction term
instead of the total energy and because
we think you're amazing equal 20 this
shows that there will be no good and
that's for sabbatical models not only
for the ground States but really for any
low energy states right even when you go
to some constant fraction of the total
energy states they are extremely
complicated but very integrals for
example while Cavett's is that for a
soda class for PCP a quantum physics you
need some kind of explain the graph this
is not very feasible below it should be
interesting Fe so maybe once we could
prove somewhat do PCP do to be some
sophisticated form of bone marrow
correction right the classical PCP
evolved a lot of nice idea seen in error
correction may be the same issue here
who knows and really I don't want to say
much about this so you can check recent
review paper by directed by in n thomas
we very nice motivate the problem and
also Thomas gave a talk here on the
first week about quantum PCP motivations
and what's not so you can watch online
alright so so before I get to the actual
content of the top which is try to give
some limitations for this for this
object let me just mention a little bit
of the history of the problem I think
the first paper that mention this
problem was paid by by a duration and
another in 2002 which was an explanation
of this kid I of smart and cool and
urine they just say well maybe you know
there is a quantum version of PCP so I
guess or away from from the beginning of
quantum np-hardness fury this problem
has been around then the first then a
please I I guess no look into the
problem then the next result for the
next time I i saw this mention he was
actually in the blog post by Scott say
called the quantum PCP manifest so also
I learn about this problem and then just
gotta show some parts if with his
permission or what he writes because
it's interesting so he wrote i'm
ninety-nine percent sure this field
projector or something close to it is
true good 95 sure that it requires it
for adaptation of class for pcp where
the original theory
in much the same way it's going to fall
tolerance require this product action of
classical for solaris and eighty-five
percent sure that it proves that you
booked in a year so should enough people
make it priority I'm satisfied surely
the proof ones that should be woken up
here for untrimmed pieces of
understanding and insight and I'm 0.01
percent sure improvements and that's why
I hereby bequeath the extra movie part
to you my readers a painfully we forgot
so we're well how how he would update
them no no okay so you know so you sure
that was right it looks like new ideas
won't need it but maybe they'll ever of
them including the last one right and
then dinner it's very nice also the the
comments are nice there are nice
discussion and all of the comments by
Scotty say that we will see later this
say I'm quite certain quality PCP fury
me requires significant new ideas we
shall I spent the neo to study here it's
proof of the classical history furin and
I found about 20 violations of the
nonlinear on every page right so I
remember really say what he means by
that I couldn't really understand so I
guess one of the ways to see the result
of this talk is to is to formalize this
bed right to see what why means to for
this classical proves to violate non
cloning and and to be very difficult to
quantize so I'll get here all right so I
guess some people took up the challenge
of all right trying to find quantum PCP
there the first results by these guys
are the rates by zephan and mesh they
start trying to study if you can
quantize you know spoof of the DCP by me
nah quantizing delude yourself the
brutal and so so they have some partial
success they could quantized version of
gaba purification by random walk and
expanders but not when you not when you
pay a large price blowing up the the
alphabets but when you blow up the
locality
your blow up the air and then there is a
quantum version of but they also notes
that you get stuck in trying to get to
get the other parts work right it's it's
a hat phone then there was another
direction try to disprove the conjecture
and there are several results i just
mentioned very briefly so so it i
arrived prove that it's show some NP
approximation for two local quantum
ostracize faction problem when they are
almost commuting okay so when they are
commuting for to open this is always in
NP is the result by rival villi so when
they are close super mutant you are a
have some more trivia proximate so it
was one results then there was some
sequence of results like just mentioned
to by hastings and friedman and what I
propose is an easier conjecture which is
also interesting is related to quantum
PCP I am and they gave some good
evidence that it's probably true and so
this is also some evidence for quantum
PCP so this conjecture they call call no
no energy trivial states just says that
you have global models what consequat no
constraint satisfaction problems for
each if you look at all all the low line
energy states okay up some constant
fraction they are all pretty complicated
so first they are not product states
that's the first step but seconds
they're not even like product states
with a constant absorb it apply to them
okay so they have some complicated thing
of instruction so of course the photo
PCP is true this conjecture is true as
well but not the opposite so it's
interesting thing to study so more
recently they all stayed by the origin
and loyola so what if what they could
get the same the approximation all 4k
for any k k local commuting quantum
prostrate satisfaction problems on it
small step expanders which have very
high extension okay and they also start
the study of quantum local tesco codes
which is a very useful important thing
in classical PCP and they also found
some limitations for these things so
this is a negative result for quantum
PCP right so usually you know if you
have a good small set expander this is
exactly the kind of graphs that you get
some classical pcp heat showing that be
this is not the right type of grass for
quantum PCP and the result that I I want
to focus on the rest of this talk is
also in the spirits of this one but it's
a little bit difference is its
approximation in mp4 now fix everything
so to local but for more computing
quantum constraint satisfaction problems
ok and now because this is like a
workshop on quantum games and protocols
I just want to phrase this this bad news
for potent PCP in the language of
protocols and games ok so this is what I
want to do in the next slides is there
in question so far it means that I will
give you a classical witness that energy
is low enough for example product States
this would be bit all right so to
populate in terms of of protocols and
games I will go see this kind of maps
which are very common in like classical
complexity theory and we and might
disappear so you want to quantize and I
want to show that this together if
quantum PCP doesn't work ok doesn't fit
you again so what are these webs so so
this is a proposition classroom ok so
i'll show you how you can idea of the
proof is very is very standards it shows
that for every integer see you can find
efficient mapping from constraint
satisfaction problem of like locality to
so every 22 alphabet Sigma and an M into
some air game locality to but some other
parameters such that the number of
variables inner of clauses they blow up
but only like no like that so it is
constant supermodel the degree of the or
image now that's it it's to local right
so there is interaction graph let's
measure the regular graph ok course in
please so the degree blows up like
explanation ok the alphabet goes up
exponentially as well now del SATs can
only grow up ok does not decrease and if
it was size 50 before it's also size
file ok so it's inoperable
air-conditioned is exactly what that
ships right now i'll show you split so
also let let's see this so one way to do
this process
so there is no particular reason why you
ain't arresting this right there are
actually it's quite useful class 3 but I
just you know I just want to yes or
there exists such make for every to
their existence maybe oh that if you
will not be great no no because because
you go up the alphabet explanation but
you also brought degree explanation so
there is a trade-off right see
increasing the degree and increase the
alphabet but later trade-off for Lucy
why why we came ok right luckily then
you should care about us but right ok so
I've achieved at so okay i wrote a large
stuff but it's not important because
knots so so the way people do
classically this is the setting of foul
a repetition ok so base what you do you
have your constraint satisfaction
problem you write as a co / label
instance there is some reduction for
that for going to detail say i don't
want to spend time on that and then you
do this area for repetition ok and now
of course i call it spread a petition
for kids because as you all complain
right so the proposition show actions
northie what's interesting about this
procedure is that as run roughshod
actually the amplifies the lsat value
explanation and that's why this
procedure is interesting but if you had
some other postage that all that
achieves this the six things and does
not open fight again would be fine as
well we don't care ok we call this this
this brownie up mix ok they brought the
degree and they blow up the alphabets
but both explanation can you remind me
what the degree was I mean old oh yeah
but I didn't so short up so you have it
you have a narrative to portray site
section prop right so you have the
parables
and because it's able to sue the
constraints they are just about like the
only actor two variables so you can
define interesting interaction graph
here right so here is one more here's
another one so the degree is just the
degree of this graph okay and we assume
this record all right so yeah yes I
don't understand so why is not identity
I mean if you are just adding dummy
edges like certainly would entail SATs
will go down if you just end dumb eh is
red if the unsub value will go down
right right yes so just adding dummy
edges will not do the job but this says
your father petitioner will do and you
don't have to put the interesting things
that Elsa actually amplifies this I
don't allow that because I like the
bottom cases will be project right look
what herbs always projectors so you just
mean you could fly back some course on
these projectors and X is what you sorry
so the growth of the elbow or putting in
apps not not the art not the obvious
work here option was why can't you just
do the identity map or something but
when you grow the alphabet you have new
cases to handle ya know the alphabet it
just hurts to her advantage no because
you can just tens or every cent with the
identity and that goes the alphabet so I
think growing the degrees but what you
have to compensate
by rolling the off this is high yeah but
you have to say what the CSP is gonna do
on these new values of the alphabet so
well at least classically it does
nothing because if you are like you
consider three coloring like if you add
extra colors you just say that those if
if if an OD has that color that's
already doomed then you are just not
then it's just not satisfied so maybe
want embedding you work events letters
it's not devastated you could trigger
the new that has all all like learn the
letter A they would have no effect on a
few sites like if your ABC begin your
idea here all as a and nothing will
change except the alphabet size
oh yeah sure yeah these two is what we
can write this tool that's the growth
grow expansion ok but ok let me show you
why why okay about this so now the
results is that suppose that we had this
a quantum version of this thing that
I've just shown out and further ahead
quantum disappear so so the results that
day it doesn't work ok one of these two
has have to be false ok so that's a
result so if for every see integers
either is efficient netting from quantum
constraint satisfaction from to
compensate satisfaction problem with the
same processes before right so you blow
up the degree you blow up the global
dimensional as a result if its size 5
with suicides 50 and their SATs can only
grow not decrease then the quantum
Pacific conjecture has to be false ok so
so I think one way to interpret these
results is this bad news of executives
program of trying to quantize the
classical proof of the quantum PCP right
because this kind of of maps it's
something very easy to come up with
costly and is actually very similar
similar trick is what you do for proving
the PCP right like this quote and
amplification is caught with the varies
around you play with its and most clever
more clever way than this and then you
get there now even if you have this
buried a cultivation of this very simple
procedure which is like maybe the
starting point of of PCP then PCP
doesn't call these pit as a whole troop
so so this shows that if you want to
find if quality speech true and you want
to prove it you must find some probably
a very different way than just try to
quantize the classical poops right
alright so now the way one way to prove
this right is using this label over yeah
this you can translate this into provo
board games like to prove the games and
then in this setting you you prove this
kind of result in then you convert back
into constraint satisfaction problem so
cluster can go from games constraints
constraint satisfaction problems very
easy what we don't know how to the
depths so after entities this this kind
of map is not related to
petition for mountain games okay yes oh
these likes this if I want to skip it
but sure yes I kinda don't bad pitch oh
yeah no I'm not yet right that's right
so right so do the good point by that
this is all in terms of constraint
satisfaction problem you subscribe
message is much nicer to work with in
terms of like interactive proves to play
interactive proofs and is actually
equivalent to this procedure quantum we
can of course justify some quantum
version of this but is we don't know if
it's related to to interactive proofs
okay which is bad news right because if
you could relate them maybe this would
be is our way of disproving quantum PCP
right but we don't know how to do that
okay alright so so that what you want to
do is just to show show you why do i
right why this theorem is true and the
way I won't do that to connect to
something very interesting if you lament
about about entanglements cual
correlations which is what we go
anything on monogamy okay so this is the
main idea behind behind this result then
there are just should so we hear a lot
about and take a mulatto meet this week
I think let me just introduce the idea
just with a simple examples so one
example is suppose that we have a states
right road between Alice and Bob and
it's a pure state and thank you part
sick you like a UK up here there is a
easy exercise to check that if you
consider any tripartite quantum states
which has roiled via the reduction they
have to have this form right they have
to be product with C so the fact that L
will be a very table Tim plies that it
has to be productivity right so now you
see a classical of course this doesn't
happen right I'm trying number of class
postseason can be perfectly correlated
quantum this is not the case another
interesting theories what if the table
is more global right so we have this cat
steak so all the of all parts is a 1 2
a.m. they are in 0 states plus
requisition all in the one state then
this looks like
right a monogamous being la violated
right so everyone is highly entangled
with everyone else but it's not true if
you look in the right way so here we are
interesting what happens to the
bipartite reduced density matrix so we
look at role for aiha right we trace out
over all the rest and then it is to see
that this is a separable state right
this class and correlated but there is
no anything about any more so so one way
to think about monogamy is just in terms
of Tony okay so it's a bush the antenna
monogamy is a version of the non cloning
theorem but for quantum states a static
version so how it's one way to see this
collection is to show that if you could
violate malaga me you could come and if
you could call it good battle it one arm
right so this is very simple let me show
you suppose we have I ETA up there let's
Foley had a quality machine like here
okay so what you can do you can prepare
an EP out there between a and B and you
send be through the cloning machine but
now you have a tripartite state a b1 b2
and a is much too entangled both with
you own individual right so violation of
this málaga right this by this exact
account head conversely suppose we had
valuation of mammography so we have our
state's a b1 b2 which is much metal
between 81 and is also much maintained
between a and B so now what we can do is
just we do teleportation right so i will
just put some states side we use this as
a resource for teleportation which they
were measurements and by teleportation
we know that both b1 b2 will get this
quantum information we get these states
so we have a promotion okay so but the
advantage of working with an take a
monogamous that's right we don't have to
think about any and you like my lyrical
process now is something about quantum
states is 0 or me all right so what's
what's intuition behind is a terrible
other means that i already said but one
is that a if you look at the movie pass
code states like here the you look at
the subsystem a the subsystem can only
be substantially entangled with a few of
the beasts right it cannot be very much
integral with many of the B's right
that's the intuition so how it ain't
good
a convenience of the size of a of course
is if a is huge you can have an epi pair
with which one of the bees right but as
soon as a fixed size then one more movie
starts to kick in and now really the the
way to study modem is try to make it
quantitative right to understand what
statically how this mall of america
tears there are several years of doing
that then you see doing this week many
of them so I think Patrick stop on first
day we see how to study all of them
using entangled measures writes a way of
quantifying entanglements and you can
see how how they behave if you have
multiple states like this we can also
study and take monogamy in specific
tasks and see how it manifests itself so
you can think of quantum key
distribution for example manifestation
of entanglement Ogilvie right because a
and B are maximally entangled Eve has to
be d correlated and therefore she
doesn't know anything about measurements
in the States we will see this on MIP as
well in my view within 10 minutes we
have a session you can also interpret as
end table mammography and the way of
studying painting málaga be that I want
to focus here is using what we call this
quantum definitive Europe's okay so n we
also talked about them on thursday from
a different point of view but i want to
focus on practical aspects of this kind
of theorems ok so so what they are so
let me let me show you the basic version
of this firm and it's a long history of
work section leading to it and then i
want to show the version that works for
for proving the theorem that i show you
before so the first version study is
what happens when they have a
permutation symmetric state so imaginary
have a quantum states of n particles
here are the particles ok
instrumentation symmetric in in the
sense that if you just tear Butte two of
these systems like here they state
doesn't change ok so this take these
invariants other permutations then the
results is that we take this state on n
particles and we consider reduce states
on el caso we just look at the arrow
first parts co co then for any state as
a male
it was before but it was symmetric this
will be close to a convex combination
probability bution PK of product states
rotate a local states on these
subsystems and there goes like a local
dimension to the square l / n n is the
total number of subsystems right so this
first is just complete analogy with what
we know for classical probability
distributions right there are plasma
versions of new kinetic and it tells the
same okay but I can use a much more
interesting result in the quantum
context because here is only thing about
anymore right there is only class
correlations here so so these this
quantum definity is really telling sucky
about monogamy so this is there's a lot
of work behind this is final results you
can ask whether you can improve this
error by this area's local dimension
mate is not good enough and you see
sometimes we can improve it later this
week but what I what I care about is to
find a more general results okay a
modular version of these results because
we all connect to Quantico satisfaction
problems where there is no notion of
fermentation in various there right yes
understanding something but yes if I
take the cats take a half year its
fermentation so much Oh yet and but it
doesn't fall into alright so a lot of
thousands oh it is but it's a good a
great the exact right so so if you have
like 1n subsistent right
these are the states and indeed because
I have that form but what you have to do
we have to trace out some of these
subsystems here right we have to trace
from k plus 1 up to the end sub system
so you are looking at the bigger thing
this is the late yes you look at this
moment here exactly right and then you
see right to get exactly this this
classic Korell 86 right yes yes it is
destroyed but yes because you can think
that because they State this
fermentation symmetric everyone each one
of the particles is equally entangled
with all the others right and because
it's equally entangled if all the others
if you just look at the states in the
right date of you know for example two
of the parts 1 and n 2 into several
states all right so what's what's this
version so you would like to be have
something like this but removing the
assumption of penetration in areas so
these are the results so so imagine that
we have some graph whatever you want is
regular so it's the regular the degrees
C I number of vertices em and I'll let
Rodya nqg state okay any States you'll
get then the result is that there exists
some globally several states I'll tell
you what they are such that this
condition is satisfied so first a
globally several state is just say they
can be written in this form so it's a
convex combination PK is a probability
distribution and here product states so
local states okay so this is a fully
separable state there is no entanglement
there right you can prepare these
pictures with like share and earnest and
what the result says is that of course
if you take a bad choice a pro might be
very different globally from a separable
states right what the result says is
that if you just look at local tests
then understand abandoned they start
looking more alike so what they say that
you
expectation of n so on the average you
look at the vertices on on the graph
here's the graph here the person you
look at one of these words like this and
then you look at the reduced states here
between cubits I and J so it's raw I and
J first is the same for this several
states see you my iron shape and we have
our error term okay so when they degrees
big right this is the local dimension Z
for example if it's cubits is too and
this is the degree so this shoulder when
degrees is height of the graph this
starts to get a small and this is a good
approximation right so I why this this
is a manifestation of entanglement agha
me well because the degree is the number
of neighbors that we care about in the
approximation right so you only this
might be very different from each other
but well all you care is that this to
reduce next matrix are close this 2 and
this 2 and so on so in the degree side
means that we carrots for these qubits
there a separable state should take care
of the correlations of this guy with
this one this one and this one and
degree higher more and more rights and
because each each quantum system cannot
be highly entangle with many others this
approximation gets better okay yes oh
yes oh yes but I also give some examples
maybe be clear but it's just that
imagine that each guy has a lot of
neighbors although we care about is the
correlations of this guy on average
Ruthie neighbors and because entangle
monogamy this guy cannot be highly
entangled with all of its neighbors so
the this the several states will do a
good job so let's see some examples okay
so one example is we can call logo
anything oh yes no yes it's about
quantum states yes that's right yes we
will see how to connect to this heavy
tones just in few slides by and the
chair of things about quantum states on
ok so a little boy sorry that's a little
big it's the local dimension of a
particle alright so let's see this
example I call like loco entanglements
imagine that
some of the parts are highly entangled
in the EPR states and the maximum tangle
States and the rest is whatever they can
be so satisfied there's a quantum state
and let's see what happens right so when
we have a red edge let's say that there
is a EP IPS there is a UK up a year
there is a to appear here and sauce
right here and so but if there is a
hippie appear here well what we saw
before all the other particles they have
to be in a product state with this tool
right so what happens when I j IH is red
then because this is a PR here and this
has to be separable bear is ready ok you
can offer bound by one quarter it's a
constant so it's pretty bad when you
have IP out there but for all the other
ones by a tangle monogamy they have to
be in a product states right so here we
have AP up there but this means that
this has to be no products is this guy
and this has been a product states right
so if you just do as our fully separable
state tensor product of the reduced
states of the one body reduce States off
road you see that we only pay I air from
the API pairs but we can only have one
EP out there / / pass code right so if
this part had a lot of neighbors in the
degrees high this approximation gets
better and better right so if you
localized anything which is fine because
you only care about the correlations on
average finish high school how will have
some global thing right so one example
we take fight the global states from the
ha measure okay this is extremely
entanglements in any where you want to
look at so it has a lot of entertainment
for example for every region X which is
like half will have the less than half
the total number of particles the
entropy which is a measure of
entanglement but its pure state is close
to maximum okay so so maybe this is a
problem but it's not really because
because the time with so global if you
look local local which is what we care
they stay true i J you can do the
calculations it's very close to the
maxilla Midstates ok so again just
putting max in mix tape everywhere are
chips here for for honda mistakes right
so the fact that entangled is global
means that you cannot access it locally
let's look at to buy a reduced as mixes
and then you don't care about it
so the fine example this ket state as
well right so these two examples before
we saw just putting a product state
synchronize the products tape does the
job in general that's not true but we
can but put your separable state works
all right so these I already show Afghan
states the reduced States there is this
class we correlated sticks the fully
separable stake would just be this guy
right and you can just check that all
the reductions are right okay all right
so so what's the corollary how you
connect to hamiltonians right it's very
simple so so this is the color you can
get if you have a G regular graph with n
variables of this form these are like
projectors then they're existe our
product States search that right this is
like the mean energy right so its energy
divided by the number of up I am right
by the number of flow constraints you
can put this is smaller than the unset
of h plus this error term okay so one
thing that is this is that if I of
course Phi is a product state right so
it's a classic witness you can write it
efficiently and you can compute this
term efficient right so all this shows
that the problem is in NP if for this
kind of error there is like local
dimension square / degree rough so this
puts the limitations on the parameters
that Squanto PCP can be true right ah so
okay now what's interesting is that in
this regime the problem is not that the
problem becomes like Impala not a
polynomial softball okay so the problem
is soo np-hard we can prove it for this
kind of parameters they probably sue NP
hugs but it's not your mate heart right
so so there's the range of parameters
for which class for PCP is true the
problem is NP hugs but quantum is the
quantity if it's true it always not all
right so okay I'm running out of time so
let me just explain how this is very
simple right so let me just explain how
the reduction works just
good to see it one more time so so so
Paul we have this Row is the optimal
assignment for the constraint
satisfaction problem okay so so is they
stated minimum energy for this
Hamiltonian by different we know that
there is this fully separable states for
which all the two-body reduce this
matrix their rights up to this arrow
right this is the theorem that i just
showed now let's open these two energies
one is this energy is trey's Sigma H for
cinematically several states / this
normalization factor and the other one
is we throw and by definition is just
the unsub family right now we know this
H is a sum of local terms so we can just
write this as expectation over this
right this local constraints of single-
road and tracing always like variation
distance for quantum states we have this
equality in my quads okay so that's
pretty standard and this is exactly what
what we know right from this Europe so
we know this is smaller than the storm
these out this is the value of our
unsub's is the energy of our of our
unsub's which is this fully separable
states this is smaller than the true and
sucks Plus this is more editor okay so
yeah so we have this data about quantum
states and edification get this result
on hammock lines now just two ends why
why this person I show you is true no it
it's pretty easy right so let's just
take a look at a case where T Square log
t / degree is more than half okay we can
always make sure this is the case by
Eddie some some dummy edges and
decreasing the unsat a little bit back
on set amount and then we make sure we
are here then we run this procedure
assuming it exists and then we know and
then we use the fury right so the
theorem says this that for the new heavy
oil HC this one amplified one this is
true but now we know the local dimension
grows explanation right so this is like
d to the power of Chi we know the degree
grows exponentially to the power of [ __ ]
so we have this term ok now if this is
more than one this decreases explanation
alright so this becomes better than
so right so this is how high should all
right so I was going to be some outline
of the pru but I don't just jump I'm out
of time so let me just summarize so so
the main main point of the book was to
show that this this phenomena of
entanglement agha me puts limitations
both on on quantum pcps on which
parameters the quarter piece we might be
true and also on approaches for proving
them right so it shows that we have to
really look at generally quantum ideas
to prove a point to pcp if it's true and
there are many open questions so the
first a more technical but i think is
very nice is that the frontier of what
we know about quantum PCP is to try to
combine these results that are
represented with the result by duration
and your that i just mentioned and what
this combination of this is to ask
whether we can find an approximation in
empty of highly expanding so like very
small or even highly in small set
expensing no i'm using key local models
okay so we got something for two local
models on general graph or general
chemical names these guys brought
something for k local but only for
communism is nice to combine them we
don't know how to do this and really
both techniques a failure there so first
our product state approximation is not a
lot to achieve that so we have to go
beyond this product states and the
technique they use which is based on
this bra july idea that i can explain I
also fails because this only works for
computing models so it's it would be
nice to find some common ground there so
can we relate these quantum blowing up
maps to to quantum games right maybe
that's a way of show you that they
exists and disprove the conjecture I
have no idea it seems hard so at the
annual top so about can we prove this
clock instructions to improve the gap
maybe it's possible oh yes
oh yeah he's exactly this very waste
right so so classically this quantum
blowing map about growing up maps you
can relate them to this interactive to
prove systems right soul from from a
protocol for to prove interactive system
you can't construct this map okay
quantum we don't know that right no so
no because this this question be the
question you asked will be maybe in the
direction of proving the codpiece p is
true right this would be proven that
it's not true but because if we can
construct the quad to bring up map then
a conjecture is not true what do PCP
equivalent statement for the PC the
question rights right but this is a
different question right this is just
about we i define this notion of quantum
blowing up map if you look at the class
called ocean this is the same as far a
repetition for quant for classical games
but this does not appear to be the same
as probably a petition for quantum games
so the question is whether you can
connect the two and there's yet another
connection that we don't know it is
that's right yes a different collection
is exactly where the like MIT with
entanglements has some connection with
quantum PCP that's right yes this is
specific to just too low Fei Xiong was
total oh yes if you try to use gadgets
to yeah so um a simple question so there
is we try to do that okay you don't have
a pool that doesn't work but they're not
here for ya know right so what happens
is that this gadget once you put them
you have all these new like cubed set
introduced and the degree from any of
them is very low okay and we have a
version for average degree but this mode
for n secret that we have is not really
every degrees like know the average of
one of the degree stuff like this
doesn't doesn't work and then I feel
there is a good reason because this this
perturbation favorite tricks you can
show that seem you can see that in many
cases they state had more of
entanglements okay it's not this product
states and we really just throw you off
the other thing all the entanglement so
they I feel there is some reason why
it's not work most of the Metro reasons
but it's not completely out here safe so
okay everything was about product states
there are nice butts that exist come up
with examples right we they will not
work very well there's a whole like fury
of trying to expand this product stays
more complicated states like this dance
or network states would be nice to see
if we can understand them better write
the power of this dancer network states
and of course so prove of this proof but
anticipate it will be the final thing so
take
yeah not matter I know oh I mean only
okay so i can show you this but we have
this cause this cause brain persian
right where you you have big rut you
cause great into into like regions the
balls here regions and now you
understand how well be put up big
product state do the job so like there
is a any state here and sit here and so
on and then you can get improved fees
like in terms of expansion in terms of
average and payments so they still the
only see Daniel in terms of more
interesting like peso network states
like awesome they apply to products
States I don't know anything but it
would be nice look yes
so you can extend it to cake pathway
States but they don't get these in terms
of the degree only so you will get so
for example if you have a complete graph
okay then the result works for where is
this result so if you have a complete
graph so like this of other end there
this works for up to I think e square
root and subsystems here but only gets
these terms of degree if if is 42 by
religiousness mix so yep
I just wanted to ask you to go back
today to the proof of your amazing so
you have already broken disc on the
authorial statement about quantum states
and so can you go back to the main see
proof of the main crm like off of this
guy of that guy how does okay come
together yes all right yes okay good so
okay so supposed to have this mapping
you know let's look at this Hamiltonian
HT ok so now let's apply this community
fee for quantum states to HT so this
body gives right the corollary action
that can help you can find a product
state this Phi is a product state right
for which the energy is more than unsat
plus a small error and the error terms
like local dimension fought for the tea
the version / degree now these guys by
that some people oh this is exponential
in C and these explanations as well so I
have this right so I have an exponent in
Te or not but by just putting some belly
edges you can always make sure that this
is true right this model so this is
model they want you so this goes to 0
exponential in T right so just to see a
lock and you have here as more air as
you want right but then this is we
cannot be true because you can decide
whether the original one right if you
can you can estimate the mean energy of
this to any acre see once and therefore
also solve the original problem right
for if you want sighs fight with
suicides Bible if it was not at some
points you see that the energy cannot be
that smoke
thank you